il y à bien longtemps dans une galaxie
lointaine très lointaine
un cataclysme cosmique school espace
temps et produit un message qui parcourt
l'univers à la vitesse de la lumière sur
terre le compte à rebours est lancé
en 1,3 milliard d'années la vie va
devoir évoluer et produire
l'intelligence qu'il faut pour détecter
ce mystérieux signal
c'est l'histoire de ce secret caché dans
les équations d'un génie
et qui lance une des plus grandes
collaborations scientifiques de tous les
temps
plus de 1000 chercheurs et ingénieurs
vont devoir construire les plus grandes
machines du monde vont-ils y arriver à
temps
[Musique]
une aventure humaine qui efface les
frontières
[Applaudissements]
mais le défi est immense ces femmes et
ces hommes vont devoir lutter sans merci
pour combattre les bruits de fond qui
masque le signal
[Musique]
sans baisser les bras ces équipes de
passionnés vont se relayer jour et nuit
pour tenter de détecter l'un détectable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire des ondes
gravitationnelles
et l'aventuré ne fait que commencer